we're on the side of the highway about
20 miles outside of Reykjavik you can
see this little guy spinning around all
day powering telecommunications
equipment back in downtown reykjavik
there's smaller versions of this sitting
on top of a bus stop they're powering a
Wi-Fi base station and advertising board
and a smartphone recharging station
in an industrial suburb on the edge of
reykjavik the company called Icewind has
set up shop in an abandoned coal power
plant to build these turbines by hand
it's run by thor the company's business
chief and see thor a former nuclear
engineer this type of turbine is called
the 7:00 news rotor collectors wind
turbine in case you missed it that would
be a savonius vertical access wind
turbine for all you turbine noobs out
there technically it's an old technology
I mean it dates back to the Persian
Empire or something we have taken this
base design and kind of brought it to
the modern age with modern materials
carbon fiber or stainless steel we've
made it really really strong we have
engineered and cut the blades so that
the turbine never goes on over spin and
we just done the system so it's really
really simple and therefore we can keep
the price down but it also can take a
really really harsh weather
and weather is a serious problem this is
what can happen to a conventional wind
turbine when excessive wind speeds hit
in Iceland windmills can last for about
three years before the weather does them
in
the shape of the ice wind turbines
allows them to function in low wind and
to stop from spinning out of control and
high rate
and beyond that they just look cool
people when they look at it they don't
realize what it is they just think it's
a sculpture or something they're not
thinking about this as an ugly energy
production price so we started putting
more emphasis on the design itself how
it looks all the curves and stuff like
that I swing has trials running
throughout this country and expects to
be in selling its turbines worldwide
later this year Thor is anxious to test
out Iceland's ingenuity on a bigger
stage
we've been isolated for a long time and
I think we're fought for a long time for
several different things this is part of
the fighting inventing new things and
going new way
you